What up what up what up, what up?
It's your boy. Et, that's right yours truly when you want to succeed as bad as you want to breathe then you'll be successful
Everyone what's up, man you got all the stuff you got you got it all
But you will not outwork me cuz your height has nothing to do with my work
Ethic your face has nothing to do with my workout no to bad background had another doing my workouts
You will not work me. I don't care. How good you are okay?
How bad you are you got to get those reps in there is no
excuse for not living up to the fullest potential no excuse I
Told you I didn't get a new daddy. I didn't get a new mama
What change I change and I stop being a victim? What's up in seven my one word is believing?
I believe in you I believe you have an amazing gift inside you that I want to see
Explode out onto the world now
I started that mentor me series to try to learn from people who've done a lot more than us and hopefully by hanging around them
Spending a little more time with them
some of their
Mindsets that belief systems a way of thinking and seeing the world seep into us to help us become the best version of ourselves
So today, we're going to learn from one of the best Eric Thomas and how to maximize your productivity
enjoy
You will not outwork me. It's not about being the best motivational speaker in the world
It's about being the most
Consistent motivational speaker in the world and so when you watch me even if you don't like me and you're into
Motivation you got a fool with me. Why cuz I'm on everything a team was that you wanted Ickx commercial yep
It was see you do this day after day
Dedicating your life to the search for a few more feet et you doing stuff with the Olympics absolutely
Et was that you own it. Yep. That was me he cheated to do that yep
You saw me what you doing some for Cleveland on the JavaScript. That was me you will not work me high school dropout
Yes, your vocabulary count is deeper than mine. Yeah, absolutely. Yep. You look better than me suit asymmetric look it up
You got me beat all day. You got me grew up on the other side of town two pairs great network
You got I'm not gonna. Lie you waiting, sweeter than I am you got all the stuff you got you
Got it all but you will not outwork me cuz your height has nothing doing my work
Ethic your face has led to doing my workout
No, too bad background had another doing my work as you well know I work me
Oh Joe jet he will not work me and your bitly you will not work me and there those of you in this room the
Reason why this stuff ain't happening for you cuz you getting out works come on call the best
motivational speakers in the world give us seven days
Let us go on over the world and speak come on
And why are you in the green room putting on your makeup? You will not work me. I'm being real
You will not outwork me while you do a photoshoot
You won't I work it job being I worked in your marriage your being out working your job your being out work with your kids
Your kids in the gang. Why cuz somebody loving on them, or do you love it over?
There in the game in the game cuz you ain't hardly at all
You'll be I worked you got somebody else in the hood who got more. They got your kid here more than you got them
And you like I just can't believe this society day. It's not the society you got out worked
Some dude up the block. Let's get it spending more time with your son
You are some guy on the block is telling your daughter
How cute she is are you not cuz you're grinding you working, but you thought when I told you 120?
I just mean it worked. I mean everywhere you will not outwork me
You might make money, but your marriage might not be I'm gonna get you on all fronts
Alright now watch this cuz you're a procrastinator
And this is how I did I said the last time you wrote a book you got the three you got the four chapters
So the first thing I need you to do is just get to chapter three chapter four
Right when I got to chapter four I said just get to chapter salmon. Don't worry about finishing the whole book
Don't worry about this big goal because every time you set this big goal
You never get it accomplished because you never break it up in manageable pieces
So after I got the chapter for us like yo, he let's get five six seven go
But when I got the chapter seven I knew it was only listen to me
I knew I only had to write 14 chapters, and I said I'm halfway there baby. I'm halfway there when I got the seven I
Did 14 or my editors got to the chapters?
They say you could break 14 into 21, and it turned into 20 listen told me 21 chapters
212 pages alright, so I'm this is it I'm talking to my procrastinator
You still have time don't quit don't give up you still have time you can do it
You can make it happen, but you can't do it procrastinate
You can't do it talking about it right practice practice practice reps reps reps
I can't wait to the big gigs to speak. I got to get my reps in I don't care
How good you are I don't care
How bad you are you got to get those reps in so make sure you do this listen to me
And I told you how many times a day what you doing this?
three times a day morning noon
Night come on. This ain't rocket science. I want you to do a win
Morning noon night. Look one was not a lot of us. I need you here you morning noon night
90 straight days all right, so y'all know we went from the backyard
We did this here, right we didn't get we did high schools like Froome
Just keep practicing it ain't rocket science
You keep doing it 30
Days 90 you start all over
You go to another level 30 days six to eight ninety day you like why am I not going to that because you're not doing
30 days a day nine day
Now you might not even make it like you might not even whatever you say he was gonna
Do it might not even less 30 days you might do 10 and quit
What's your win it? All do you even know?
But do you know what your win it all is for this year like do you know if this year ended like what you gonna?
Happen like do you know or you're just waking up playing craps with your life
You just hope it rolled on what you wanted to roll on you playing a lottery with your life
You just hope and you put the numbers in and they come out right for you 30 60 90
30 60 90 more than new nights make the adjustments whatever you're doing that's not good quick
You're getting like a D. I see okay
We do you got 71% you're doing something wrong look if you've got an 80% you're doing some work
If you've got an 89% you're doing some work
Oh, you might be sweet 89 might be sweet, but we got 11% for what that's leprosy growth right there
It's not until you getting 100% that you need to stop right so
30-60-90 say it with me 30 60 90 come on 30 69 and then we do what?
We start all over again by that time. It's a habit. If you really want to be dominant in your field
30-60-90 start all over again 30 60 nights. I don't get morning you night. All right
Y'all got to do me a huge favor all right look. I know I know the power one trust me look
Don't get you analytical there
I know the power of one but I'm telling you sometimes to make a milestone become a reality
You got to get it done by tools one of the greatest basketball players that ever played the game yep Mike with Jordan
I
Enjoy, they do it alone come on oh
You got when you say Mike you gotta say Scottie Pippen
Are you hear me la la, baby?
When you say Kobe Bryant like real real you you can't go without saying when you talk about that era you can't go without saying
Shaky low Neil are you hearing me sometimes you up the power one is great MJ
Was doing his thing on the solo, yup, Kobe was doing his thing on the solo?
but you got to keep it 100 when Jordan had Scottie ah
magical
magic happen Oh
Shaq was with, Kobe ah
Magic I been and what I'm telling you is as long as I was doing it by myself
Yeah, as long as I was doing it by myself
I could never get that dissertation done the power of to know man
And I mean it no man is an island
And let me tell you what change the game would change the game is when I met with dr. June
What changed the game is when I sat down with dr. June, and I had some accountability can I say it?
Accountability partner your problem is you're doing it by yourself
Your problem is you don't want nobody to know that you got I know I know you're afraid for them to see your
Weaknesses. I know you're afraid to be vulnerable
Yup, you're afraid to tell them your dream. You look you got to tell somebody
Somebody got to hold you accountable
I'm not telling you to tell the world
But one other person needs to know and one other person needs to hold you accountable and my life changed
My milestone became a reality
Listen to me. I'm giving you the secrets of success today. I told dr. June. I want to get it done and dr.
June looked me in my face and said don't play with me don't play with me
Are you ready look not only do I have a PhD?
But not only about sat on many committees listen to me very closely I can and will help you to get through this
But don't play with me you got to be
Serious and doc said all I need you to do you tell you tell me you tell me when you want this PhD you tell
me when you
To be finished with this dissertation you tell me when you chill and I'll tell you how how I'll tell you what you have to
Do every single day how many are pages you have to write how much research I do how much time you have to spend on
It listen to me. It did not become a reality it didn't become real into our sat down with dr. Jr.
We made a commitment
Are you hear me before it was just an idea before it was just a thought before it was just something I said
But when I sat down in my log in my no
sir man mano-a-mano
Man the man when I sat down
And I made that commitment and I took his hand when I looked him in his eyes and said I'm ready to get it done
All we did was meet every Monday. Are you hearing me? I know this sounds too simple. I know it sounds, too
Good to be true. All we did was sit down on Mondays at 9 o'clock and every single week
He said this is what you need to get done if you are a man
And you do what you say you're gonna do and you make no excuses, and you don't let nothing get in your way
I
guarantee you in a year's time if that's how long you want this process to take I
Guarantee you we can get it done what I can't do is
I can't do it for you, but I can show you what it takes to me
And I didn't want there was a part of me that I never really wanted to link up with nobody else because I really didn't
Want to fully expose myself I didn't really he said to me kid you've never written a dissertation
Before how would you know how to do it? That's what I'm here for
And when you get that life coach?
That's the problem with some of you
You can't get to that next level because you're trying to do it on your own you're trying to do it in your own strength
and I'm not saying there's no power and one mic was murdering the game putting up 60 something against a
Boston mic was dunk contest mic was doing it
But might never reach those milestones by himself he had to bring somebody else into his sphere of influence
Hey listen. Let me just explain something y'all. I gotta keep the water c.j. 12 years younger than me
I was out of high school before this boy was even really born
Are you hear what I'm saying my man 12 years younger than me 12 years
And he picked up that phone, and yet oh he had one of them are to heart
Do you have anybody in your inner circle? That's willing to be real with you?
That's willing to keep it 100 that don't care none about your feelings, but they care about your goals and your dreams
CJ hit me up I called my man love per message like see they killing me they want to know when the mixtape coming out
When is the next mixtape coming out see see set Ichi let me tell you something shut it down
I said what he said shut it down shut the television ain't no mixtape coming stop doing TG
I shut it down. That's why you got the reruns for so long. He said shut it down he shut it down
I'm tired. He said we'll keep it. Well. I'm tired eat the last true mixtape
You was talking about how you gonna get your PhD between me
and you
He mano a mano man the man we will not come out with another mixtape were you talking about what you gonna do shut it
all down
Eat do you understand that that the future of this company is on you finishing his ph.d
Shut the gigs down shut it down
And I'm telling y'all one of the bay up one of the ways your boy got the milestone done
I had to shut it down. I said down the phone called flat out from a certain time
Don't call my house if you love me
Text me if you love me
And they ain't no emergency don't go I had to shut it down shut the TV down
listen to me put the
controllers down
shut down born out soul it on the weekend born in the club look shut it down shut down your favorite team stop watching your
Favorite football or basketball, or socks whatever it is shut it down
And I'm telling you you ain't got to shut it down for the rest of your life
But you got to set it down long enough, so you can get your balls on ya
So you can get your NBA final done. Yeah? Yeah, yeah, yeah, so you get your World Series, done. Yep?
Are you here? So you don't national titles. Oh are you here?
So you can get joke book dog so you just joke CDs finish?
So you can get your degree so you can take your marriage to the next level shut it down
I had to shut the noise down
I had to shut it down when I shut it down when I shut certain things down in my life
boom
I went to a whole of the level 80 why do you speak with so so much authority?
because I'm talking about my life not something that I read I ate out of trash cans I
Had no business eating out of trash cans I lived in abandoned buildings. I had no business living in abandoned buildings
But ET your daddy wasn't in your life your mom was a teenage mother you you grew up come on eat look at your shirt
that's not an excuse there is no excuse for not living up to the fullest potential no excuse I
Told you I didn't get a new daddy. I didn't get a new mama
What change I changed and I stopped being a victim?
I stopped saying I've gotta wait for good things to happen to me, and I said I'm gonna grind. I'm going to fight
I'm going to work. I'm going to press forward. I'm going to learn. I'm going to do everything in my power every
Single day, I'm going to do everything in my power to become a Victor and not a victim now
Let me say this before I move forward, and I can't explain it, but you better feel me winners win and losers lose
I can't explain it any better than that
I don't know how it happens, but winners win
And if you create a culture of losing if you keep being a victim if you keep letting
losing happen to you if you keep letting people do you and treat you any kind of way it's going to become a
Culture let me tell y'all how much I'm not I'm not from New Zealand guys come on listen to me very closely
I'm not from New Zealand
But I know about what let me say it this way so I can help you I know about what team
I'm not never seen I've never seen All Blacks and play a day in my life. I've never been to the stadium. Where's the stadium?
Help me out. Where's the stadium? Okay? I'm going to see right
You said sure did I've never been to the stadium you like Eric the stadium. That's Hobbit that way here
That's not the stadium the stadium is this way I've never been there a day in my life
And if you watch some of my videos I have all blacks in my video. Why cuz they're what?
They're winners, and when you're a winner
You don't even stay in your own little town when you were a winner winning spreads, so
Everybody I got videos where I'm like y'all. I don't really know how to show my passion somebody said get the All Blacks
I'm like yep. That's what I need All Blacks
Yo, I need to all blacks I need aa quack cuz they say what I'm sayin, they just said it in rugby
I don't sound have done it. I'm like woo. That's a violent sport
That passion is all over there. Why cuz winners win I?
Can't explain it to you
But you better stop making excuses and find a way to win because once you start winning you go from
1,500 to 3,000 to 5,000 to 7,000 you remember see from seven to ten
Nothing changed. We're still in the basement. We don't have a building
We still use the garage for all of our products we
Don't have business cards. We don't have a five-year plan
We don't have a three-year plan
How do you do it, then Eve me wake up and grind winners win I focus more on winning?
And I focus on structure I focus on winning and when you become a winner
They start seeing you with winners. This is a personal shout out. Thank you so much. Thank you for
valuing our content and more importantly
thank you for taking the time that you have to actually put it in a
Way where you can not only use it for your platform
But use it to inspire people look you know why we do what we do
I know you get it like all we want to do is inspire and it motivate the world daily when I say the world
I'm talking about our teachers. I'm talking about parents. I'm talking about husbands wives
Look athletes professional athletes college athletes look. Just just the
engineer just
Average people all we want to do is inspire the world so again on behalf of myself and the ETA family
Thank you for using your platform and look
I looked at your platform, and I see the lineup you have and it is an honor to be considered
Among some of the great so our only wish as we move forward into this year
Is that we will continue to create the type of?
Content that you can continue to use to share with the world, so thank you from the bottom of our heart
You don't you didn't have to do it all right? You didn't have to include us. I just want to say. Thank you
Thank you. Thank you. I want to say to you
And everybody on your team and in your platform. Please do us a favor make the rest of your lives
for best of your lives
Now I've got a special ET bonus clip for you
But before getting to that my question of the day is what is your number one productivity tip or hack?
I want to hear from you leave it down in the comments below. Thank you so much for watching
I believe in you. I hope we continue to believe in yourself and whatever your one word is much
Love I'll see you soon, and enjoy the bonus
If you're gonna do what you say you're gonna
Do be what you say you're gonna be you're gonna have to line me out that gazelle stop
I'm trying to tell you you were gazelle you gonna come up short
You were gazelle you're not always gonna get what you want out of life you a gazelle it's gonna
Be even have an average experience you a student. I need you in lion mode you a teacher
I need you in line mode you an entrepreneur
I need you in line mode you try to lose weight lion mode you can't do nothing significant in gazelle mode nothing
Nothing impressive happens in gazelle mode nothing happened when you run it
Nothing happening run mode give up mode quit mode scared mode fearful more nothing happens
Everything that happened in line mode like I'm coming to get you
I love y'all obviously the one where the lioness is kind of sitting there
And she double-dutch it and all the beast is running by and they just keep going
And she just in preparation mode and out of nowhere. There is no no music no no preparation
You just see my man come out of nowhere and just boom Bob grab one who?
Will rip your heart out. That's lion mode. You got to get to a place when you start executing somebody just helped me out
Last year the greatest news in the NBA
the greatest story in the NBA last year was what brightest story told in the NBA last year
Offseason was what Kevin Durant left go to Golden State?
Durant like I'm out I don't know where y'all come from but that hurt our because they supposed to be boys
Look at this picture for a minute because this way if you're gonna be successful
This is where I need you to go right here
what a pig
this was the one when you play your boy first game you and your homie was cool right and this is where you
emotionally cut it
This one you got my man this will you see my man, and he's trying to be cool
He shot act like he leave you high and dry
He tried to act like the goals of the dreams you I had this the one where he cop it
And you look my man this place and say you get it to me, and that's what most of you will never be successful
Cuz there's some stuff in your past you keep holding on keep and you got to get to a point when you read it
Right and you ready to get to the next level
Do you look at people used to be close to and say you dead to me?
You did
Triple-doubles we shouldn't even be talking about the MVP
Ain't nobody else keep it somehow make it close to the MVP the NBA is rigged and I'm through with him
Hey summer, many beginning to see them come up. I'm to my high octane
They said if he keep doing that all season was laughter. They said he keep running himself like that
He's gonna burn out my man ain't burnt out
He look like in close to burn out
But you know why they said it cuz they can't operate in that level for that low home
So people were trying to put they limitations on you. I can I can do six kids
I can do stopping we can leave here tonight. You can take me to a church
I give you another hour you can't do it. Don't put your limitations on me
I'm dead to your limitation your limitations don't exist in my world. Those are your limitations keep them
Don't watch them on TV. Go home read the newspaper, but go home and look in the mirror go home
Call your homeboy, and y'all talk about your lemon taste
I got nothing I get off the plane from board to Dubai and get on the crime
And I hit it and some of y'all hold on the stuff you should be holding on to it should be dancing now
I'm gonna go to a funeral if you need to get rid of that junk like Barry you have you got to do
But it's weighing. You know it's killing you every day you waking up thinking about it
You should be thinking about in the more. It should be dead to you move on
And move towards your graves. I forget those things which are behind and our breasts I
Pressed hard to think I press I don't got time for that no more. It's not personal. I got nothing against you
I don't hate you, but I love me
The most important work ever if you had to think of one word
That's most important to you. That sums you Apple, so it would be like a little beacon
Hey believe nation if you want to know what the most important one word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a very special secret video for you check the description for details